evening to you thank you for joining us
at six i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise
valdez animal rights activists say they
need the public's help finding the
person who left a dog to die in the
northeast valley the dog was found dead
inside a metal crate in an empty lot joe
mohler live near lamb and lake mead with
more on this active investigation joe
[Music]
denise bryan talk about a sad story
we're at the intersection of marion and
judson yesterday a truck driver was on
the street here found that dog in this
dirt lot in that crate and tried to help
it by the time he got out there was
already too late now pet rescuers say
they want to find the person responsible
and they need their public's help
it was
dead for a while tuesday dominica
hogaslava from pet rescue got a tip
about a dog left at this lot inside a
cage i am just heartbroken that anybody
would literally do this a truck driver
found the dog tried to help it but it
was too late the dog was dead inside the
cage this photo of the dog is blurred it
was a female sharpay the animal control
said that the dog had at least one
litter prior to being dumped she is
worried it may have been a dog used for
illegal breeding i hope that
they will find whoever did this now she
and other animal activists hope someone
has information about where the dog came
from the fact that somebody valued its
life so little that they would discard
it like trash is just it's tragic anula
wildridge is an animal rights activist
if this dog was the result of
unlicensed backyard breeding
it's a cautionary tale to all those who
are getting their pets from
people who are breeding without a
license because
those folks don't really know how the
parents are being treated both hope
anyone with information about this
sharpay will come forward i will never
understand this why will anybody do this
if you don't want your dog or you have
problems with your dog with this
behavior
reach out to any rescues take it to the
shelter don't kill it and dump it in the
desert
now back out here live again the
intersection is marion and judson the
county is investigating this but they do
need tips as well if you know anything
about this sharpay that was found here
you're asked to call animal control or
metro reporting live in the east valley
joe mohler live local now